friendly vegan healthy super easy cheap
craig student budget lazy what I eat in
a day every morning I start my day with
a coffee and a big glass of water that I
usually add some apple cider vinegar
into row tip drink this with the straws
which doesn't damage your teeth enamel
and now it's breakfast time my favorite
meal of the day
I love porridge simple porridge with
cinnamon goji berries and chai seeds
which are a good source of omega-3 and
antioxidants keep bug that it means is
known the superfood of this meal is a
banana
I just love bananas okay and how to use
that how do you make this meal super
simple just get some porridge oats put
them in a bowl get some kettle water and
please don't scorn me but yeah I'm just
using boiling water and pulling it in my
oats instead of putting it on the hob
this is just a bit quicker although you
do have to wait which is annoying after
this just give it a little stir and then
add in whatever nut milk you would like
I love almond milk it's my fave and then
I put in some of the cinnamon honestly
this makes it taste so much better if
you haven't tried porridge with cinnamon
try it
then I do banana you go to berries your
cheese seeds and maybe even as had more
cinnamon if you feel like it and that's
a pretty good start to the day in my
opinion time okay so I'm at University
now sometimes our money in for a couple
of hours a day so this is just where we
snack really I always have Apple on hand
cuz they're just super quick to snack on
and apparently they keep the doctor's
away but who knows I'm walking home now
takes about half an hour sometimes I'm a
little bit hungry so I reach for a naked
bar cashew cookie these are basically
just raisins things like that all mushed
up they are so good and I'm home it's
lunchtime and I'm usually a little bit
hungry by this point so I just want
something quick and easy so I get
whatever I can find in the fridge kidney
beans
red Chili Peppers if it's cold outside
which it is spring onions garlic
mushrooms don't forget that sriracha
sauce I like it to be
hut-hut-hut and the super food for this
meal is avocados which I will be
spreading on toast how do you make this
meal again so easy just chop everything
up and put it into a pan
I am NOT the best at chopping though I
mean just watching me do this it's
making me nervous but don't worry I
don't chop my fingers
then I add my beans some castle water
and the vegetable cubes add some veggie
stock it'll make it taste so much nicer
I also found some garlic granules so I
put some of those in there and pepper
and don't forget the sriracha sauce yeah
now while you leave that to boil you can
do your avocados so basically use cut
all the way down the middle and then
split it in half and sneakily take away
the inner core of your avocado
[Music]
once you've done this you just need to
get a spoon or a knife whatever works
and just scoop it out
[Music]
looking fab I then added a little bit of
lemon juice just to give it some more
flavor if his avocados can be a little
bit plain and I'm just using a fork yeah
that face I'm using a fork it's not the
easiest way to mash this up Tabasco
sauce yeah I decided to put Tabasco
sauce in this time I like to spice
things up a lot in my day and yeah just
mash mash a mash until it looks
something and there you have it super
quick super easy super hot for a cold
day
[Music]
now it's dinnertime and I wanted to have
some chips so I got my broccoli my sweet
corn some olives for the side and some
frozen peas as well and spinach gotta
get that iron yes and of course the
superfood for this meal is a sweet
potato
now for this you kind of need to cut
yeah I don't really want you to see this
anyway I have cut the soup potato up and
two tiny little chips or as you
Americans might say fries and drizzled
on some olive oils a precast some pepper
whatever kind of seasoning that I can
find I just go a little bit crazy just
do whatever I want to do with them
really and then it's time to pop them in
the oven I put the heat up foul and just
leave them in for 15 minutes after this
time I can take them back out to put the
broccoli on so they don't take as long
I'm just seasoning them once some olive
oil that has some chili seeds in flip
over the chips and pop them back into
the oven and now I'm kind of cheating
again always taking the easy of shoots
just getting my frozen veg and putting
some water in it and then zapping it in
the microwave for four minutes
[Music]
and then when the food is ready to come
out of the oven I carefully take it out
it's gonna be hot so don't burn yourself
and there you have it you're ready to
put it onto a plate when it cools down
I added some apple cider vinegar onto my
chips and don't forget the sbatch sauce
I realized now as well I didn't put any
olives on there but I did intend to
anyway
give this a thumbs up if you enjoyed
this a very different video for me but I
just wanted to share with you what I eat
in a day because I find these videos
pretty interesting but disclaimer no
vegetables were harmed in the making in
this video and just because I eat this
food does not mean that you should be
eating this food I just wanted to share
with you what goes on inside my belly
and put some faces on some foods have a
lovely day or evening bye